[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans le 7 8 c'est
votre émission sur TV 78 pour bien
démarrer la soirée j'espère que le
week-end a été bon au programme de
l'actualité des infos pratiques et des
idées de sortie voici le sommaire de ce
mardi 9 mai
comme tous les ans à cette date c'est la
Journée de l'Europe elle marque
l'anniversaire de la déclaration
Schumann de 1950 qui a jeté les bases de
la construction européenne que signifie
l'Europe pour vous nous sommes allés
vous poser la question et dans les
informations du jour également nous
revenons sur les travaux avenue pas du
lac à Montigny-le-Bretonneux qui impacte
votre circulation à proximité du
Vélodrome national et aussi sur les gros
bouchons ce matin en Île-de-France en ce
mardi de rentrer
c'est un rendez-vous incontournable du
mois de mai à La Nuit européenne des
musées se tient samedi prochain
plusieurs sites des Yvelines vous
accueillent le soir avec des animations
variées focus dans cette édition sur le
programme au Musée départemental Maurice
Denis à Saint-Germain-en-Laye et au
musée de la ville de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
et puis dans la partie sport les
principaux résultats du week-end dans le
département avec notamment en rugby le
résumé de la rencontre entre plaisir et
Saint-Priest 16e de finale de Fédérale 2
et les Yvelinois se sont inclinés 18 10
sur leur pelouse dimanche ils tenteront
de renverser la tendance le week-end
prochain à Saint-Priest pour se
qualifier pour la suite des fausses
finales de la compétition et ce sera
tout à l'heure dans la partie sport du 7
8 avec aussi au menu la présentation du
meeting du Gally Athletic Club plaisir
c'est ce samedi au stade Bernard Giroud
à plaisir et pour en parler romain à
vendeur viguert qui est avec nous
bonsoir bonsoir président donc du Galli
Athletic Club c'est la troisième édition
de cet événement est-ce qu'on peut
parler d'un rendez-vous qui s'installe
dans le calendrier des courses chaque
année ouais ça la première fois on l'a
mis en place pour faire découvrir aux
Yvelines les meeting athlétisme et au
fur et à mesure des éditions qui passent
on essaie de d'instaurer ça comme un
événement un événement estival de
l'athlétisme à yvinois on aura
l'occasion d'en parler tout à l'heure il
y aura à vos côtés Fabien ores qui est
vice président de la section locale du
plaisir Athletic Club en face de vous il
y a également une autre invité qui est
avec nous c'est Catherine Noël bonsoir
mère adjointe en charge de la culture à
Croissy-sur-Seine et on va parler avec
vous d'une exposition qui se poursuit à
Croatie sur scène c'est jusqu'au 16
juillet elle se nomme chien et chat elle
est visible à l'espace channelier c'est
une expo qui est donc visible grâce
aussi à la Cité des Sciences et de
l'Industrie elle est dédiée à nos amis
nos compagnons de tous les jours
proposer depuis le 17 décembre est-ce
qu'elle rencontre son succès pour le
moment écoutez elle rencontre du succès
puisqu'on arrive même à y faire venir
des écoles de Paris donc vous voyez dans
notre petite ville de Croissy-sur-Seine
où elle rencontre énormément de succès
et notamment pendant les vacances et les
week-ends
donc c'est la deuxième que nous faisons
avec eux et ça marche très très bien le
détail à suivre dans un instant et ont
pu on va parler dans le 7 8 d'un
événement
en l'occurrence c'est les enfants en
situation de handicap y compris alors
les causes humanitaires classiques que
d'autres mouvements peuvent porter aussi
mais également des questions qui
touchent au rapprochement entre les
peuples la dimension internationale de
et la paix aussi voilà la dimension
internationale de du mouvement
l'illustre un petit peu voilà et tout à
l'heure vous serez accompagné on aura
l'occasion d'en parler un peu plus tout
à l'heure d'Antoine de San et Clément
Griffo qui seront en quartet pour ce
concert ce cette soirée jazz et il
proposeront je le disais une rencontre
entre le jazz et la musique classique on
aura l'occasion d'en parler tout à
l'heure mais peut-être très rapidement
un petit teasing en deux mots alors
donc ce conserve d'abord rapidement
c'est on l'a programmé parce que c'est
pour nous aussi un soutien ça fait
partie de l'action qu'on peut mener
aussi dans sur l'aspect culturel des
choses donc on soutient effectivement le
projet French master ce qui est créé par
Antoine de saine et Clément Griffo
en hommage au compositeur de musique
classique forêt Debussy Ravel et 500 et
Satie quoi
inspire un petit peu leur démarche on
aura tout le temps d'en parlera tout à
l'heure
et donc il s'agit effectivement de
montrer de faire se rencontrer la
musique classique et le jazz comme ça
s'est passé d'ailleurs dans l'histoire
du jazz mais donc le détail tout à
l'heure dans le 7 8 bonsoir reginal de
la rédaction de tv78 avec vous dans un
instant les informations du jour à
retenir de ce mardi 9 mai et puis comme
tous les mardis les insolites de
Véronique Ithurbide ces informations
originales qui vous ont peut-être
échappé dans les Yvelines voici le menu
mais tout d'abord on va regarder les
prévisions météo de demain
[Musique]
pas ou peu d'amélioration des conditions
météo pour la journée de demain de la
pluie annoncée dans la matinée vinoise
le ciel sera légèrement plus clair vers
Mantes-la-Jolie ou dans et Rambouillet
il fera en moyenne entre 11 et 12 degrés
l'après-midi le ciel sera orageux dans
les secteurs de Rambouillet et Houdan
côté température compter 15 degrés dans
la partie nord et centre du département
14 degrés dans le sud des Yvelines et ce
mercredi 10 mai elle nous fêterons les
solanges on fait le point tout de suite
sur les informations du jour dans les
Yvelines
avec vous Régine rallès et on débute ses
actualités avec la Journée de l'Europe
célébrée en ce 9 mai et oui Grégory ce
mardi 9 mai c'est la célébration de la
paix et de l'unité entre les pays
européens une date marquant l'univers de
la déclaration du ministre des Affaires
étrangères français Robert Schuman en
1950 mais également un acte de naissance
de l'Union européenne après la période
de guerre alors ce discours majeur
exposé l'idée d'une nouvelle forme de
coopération politique pour éviter de
nouveaux conflits et à cette occasion
nous sommes partis à la rencontre des
cinq continents pour leur demander leur
vision de l'Europe les politiciens en
Europe sont remplis d'hypocrisie
quand on voit par exemple ce qui s'est
passé au Pays-Bas ce qui concerne le
coronavirus avec Emmanuel Macron on a de
quoi se poser des questions pour moi
l'Europe est un peu au pied des
États-Unis malheureusement c'est de la
concertation entre les États c'est
beaucoup de politiques commun es c'est
un Parlement européen et puis c'est un
cadre supérieur à l'échelle nationale en
fait
ils sont méchants
il nous aide pas
et dans le département des Yvelines est
présente la maison Jean Monnet en des
principaux fondateurs de l'Union
européenne dans la commune de
Bazoches-sur-Guyonne on prend maintenant
la direction Nanterre où s'est tenue une
manifestation ce week-end Nanterre dans
les Hauts-de-Seine mais une actualité
qui a un lien avec les Yvelines tout de
même
7 mai ça a marqué en fait les un an de
la prise d'otage de Cécile colère et de
son mari Jacques Paris donc cette
professeur qui enseignait dans les
Yvelines elle a été arrêtée lors de son
séjour touristique en Iran parce qu'elle
est soupçonnée d'espionnage par les
autorités locales et à l'heure actuelle
les proches dénoncent une détention
arbitraire et sans fondement les
informations du jour en ce mardi mardi
de rentrer et c'était compliqué sur les
routes franciliennes tout à fait plus de
650 km de bouchon ont été enregistrer ce
matin en Île-de-France selon les
chiffres de citadins et en cause les
fortes pluies qui se sont abattues sur
Paris et sa région et les retours du
long week-end et des vacances qui n'ont
sans doute pas arranger la fluidité du
trafic et puis si vous habitez où vous
travaillez également à Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines vous avez peut-être aussi vécu
la galère des bouchons ce matin à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux des travaux ont
débuté sur l'avenue du pas du lac entre
le centre commercial de Skywest et le
vélo Drôme national l'objectif est
d'assurer la remise la remise en état
des des joints du pont proche du site
olympique et de changer la main courante
des garde-corps la circulation sur cet
axe sera interrompue dans les deux sens
jusqu'au 7 juillet 2023 de 9h30 à 16h et
des prévises et des déviations pardon
seront proposés aux horaires de
fermeture et puis à partir de ce mardi 9
mai le commissariat d'Élancourt et la
brigade de Magny-les-Hameaux expérimente
le télé service de visioplinte proposé
par le ministère de l'Intérieur et des
partenaires et à 50 ans en Yvelines 9
communes sont concernées Coignières
Élancourt Guyancourt la verrière
Magny-les-Hameaux Maurepas
Montigny-le-Bretonneux trappe et Voisins
le bretonneux vous me parlez à présent
d'une assemblée départementale qui va
réunir en fond jeunesyvelinois à partir
de septembre oui avec Grégory et cette
assemblée est organisée par le
département des Yvelines avec notamment
le soutien de l'Université Paris
Nanterre le but est de créer un espace
de citoyenneté aux jeunes âgés de 7 à 21
ans afin de leur permettre de réfléchir
et de faire des propositions sur la
prévention et la protection de l'enfance
dans les Yvelines donc la protection de
l'enfance qui est une compétence du
Département et puis trois autres séances
de travail sont prévues d'ici le mois de
juin 2024 sur des thématiques qui seront
identifiées par les jeunes merci Régine
et si vous aussi près de chez vous vous
êtes témoin d'un fait qui vous fait
réagir dans l'actualité n'hésitez pas à
le partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le hashtag 78 news
[Musique]
c'est un signe de soutien à cette Europe
qui est imparfaite mais qu'on souhaite
encore faire avancer des bruits de
retour de l'Assemblée nationale c'est
que y compris dans les rangs de la
macronie et de la droite personne
comprend ce que ce texte vient faire là
c'est pas une priorité il y a des gens
qui sont pourris il y a des gens qui
sont contre c'est même il y a même pas
de clivage en tant que tel de partie
moi je pense que c'est pas c'est pas
nécessaire
et puis si on veut faire aimer l'Union
européenne aux gens je pense que le
meilleur moyen de faire ça c'est que
cette institution soit véritablement
démocratique et qu'elle soit réformée et
que aujourd'hui il y a une symbolique
derrière tout ça quand même c'est qu'on
a on perd de plus en plus de
souveraineté nationale face à une
souveraineté qui elle encore une fois et
contestable en termes démocratique au
niveau européen émission pas fort
retrouver à retrouver en intégralité dès
demain mercredi 10h30 sur TV 78 et dès à
présent sur TV 78.com on va ouvrir une
page dédiée aux actualités culturelles
dans les Yvelines
[Musique]
et on débute avec la Nuit européenne des
musées elle aura lieu ce samedi à 13 mai
pour ça 19e édition dans les Yvelines
une vingtaine de musées châteaux vous
ouvrent leurs portes avec au programme
et des visites gratuites on va mettre le
focus et le curseur sur deux sites avec
Pierre marivottier bonsoir
bonsoir bonsoir Pierre Marie chargée du
développement touristique et de la
politique des publics pour le musée
départemental Maurice de nions on le
rappelle situé à Saint-Germain-en-Laye
et à vos côtés Frédéric debuch bonsoir
vous êtes vous conservateur le
conservateur au musée de la ville de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on le rappelle
aussi situé à Montigny-le-Bretonneux au
sein du mumède petit tour de table pour
commencer qu'est-ce que ça représente
pour vous la Nuit des Musées pourquoi
c'est un événement important qu'il faut
défendre Frédéric de bus
dans l'activité d'un musée l'équivalent
des journées du patrimoine pour le
patrimoine et pour nous c'est une
manière de donner une visibilité
importante sur sur notre lieu sur nos
activités sur nos propositions
d'exposition notamment voilà c'est un
grand moment de l'année l'occasion un
autre moment Pierre-Marie Gauthier
découvrir un musée là en nocturne
qu'est-ce que ça représente pour vous la
Nuit des Musées c'est une occasion de
vivre le musée autrement dans tous les
musées c'est une soirée où on va choisir
des mises en scène originales que ce
soit sur sur des ateliers ou sur des
visites ou sur de la danse c'est une
manière c'est un temps pour créer des
rencontres inattend
inattendu et qui vont permettre aussi de
renouveler les publics qu'on va tout
qu'on va toucher et c'est également un
temps de gratuité ce qui permet aussi de
toucher un public beaucoup plus large
très important de dire effectivement que
cet événement est gratuit autour de la
table Régine Catherine est-ce que vous
avez déjà visité un musée à l'occasion
de la Nuit des Musées la Nuit européenne
des musées
mais du coup je vais je vais recommencer
pour cette année Catherine Noël
à Croatie aussi on a un petit musée deux
petits musées qui vont ouvrir pour la
Nuit des Musées le musée de la
Grenouillère notamment donc oui oui on
l'a déjà fait et on participe beaucoup
de sites dans les unes c'est aussi vous
attendez beaucoup de monde sur sur ces
soirées en général Frédéric debuch c'est
fréquenté oui oui alors si on en juge
par la fréquentation l'année dernière il
y avait beaucoup de monde plus de 1000
personnes musées voilà c'est une belle
une belle opération et j'espère qu'on
aura autant de monde cette année c'est
la même chose pour le musée Maurice de
Nice pour notre musée c'est
habituellement la deuxième journée la
plus importante de l'année après les
journées du patrimoine donc c'est
vraiment un temps majeur on va parler du
programme dans vos musées respectifs et
débuté par le musée de la ville de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui s'est
associé à la médiathèque du canal pour
une soirée en apesanteur à quoi faut-il
s'attendre Frédéric debuch oui alors
comme l'expliquer effectivement Pierre
Marie ce sont des des événements qui
permettent de proposer une autre lecture
des collections du musée une autre
approche et on de capter aussi un
nouveau public un public familial public
local ou extérieur et cette année on
propose des activités et une
programmation en lien avec notre
exposition spéciale quand le la concasse
spatiale inspire le design
actuellement musée de la ville qui a été
inauguré en février et donc on a une
série de propositions autour de la
thématique de l'espace naturellement
pour coller à cette exposition
temporaire il y a aussi une semble alors
j'ai vu dans le programme on pourra
réveiller notre âme de Jedi qui
sommeille en nous il y aura une
initiation sabre laser
il y a des animations à côté de la
découverte des musées alors il y aura
beaucoup d'animations à la fois sur le
parvis devant le mymède et à l'intérieur
du
mumet à la fois musée et médiathèque
puisqu'effectivement comme on l'a
rappelé nos collègues de la médiathèque
s'associent à cette à cette soirée et
donc voilà différents événements
très très diversifié à la fois du
spectacle de rue avec
une association qui va présenter une
déambulation en ville et un spectacle
sur sur le parvis
des animations avec une association
lacia qui est une association pour la
création et l'innovation en action
culturelle qui a proposé à la fois des
simulations avec de la réalité de la
réalité virtuelle des simulations de vol
spatial ou d'une
d'une d'un moment de vie dans la navette
spatiale internationale ou alors des des
créations de fresques collectives ou de
sculptures collective également en
réalité
virtuelle donc voilà des animations très
interactives ouvertes à tous les publics
et puis vous l'avez rappelé
le sabre
[Musique]
en tout cas des animations parce que oui
des musées c'est l'occasion de
redécouvrir un autre moment les
collections des musées les expositions
quand il y en a euh en ce moment et
aussi proposer des animations et c'est
une soirée qu'on rappelle qui est
gratuite du côté du musée du Maurice
Denis alors vous proposez vous de
multiples animations entre ombres
chinoises croquis visite guidée c'est ça
en précisant aussi qu'il y a toujours
une exposition aussi sur sur le le site
du musée Maurice Denis oui et vu que
c'est une exposition qui approche de son
terme elle se termine le à 2 juillet
c'est la dernière occasion d'y entrer
gratuitement ainsi que de voir les
sculptures d'une artiste contemporaine
qui s'appelle Cécile rénale
exactement et c'est vraiment sur sur la
femme à la fois
à la fois comme comme
sujet comme comme modèle mais
également comme artiste entre autres
dans les années 50 ou cette carrière
d'artiste femme n'était pas forcément
aussi simple la médiation qu'on va
proposer pour cette soirée c'est un peu
une médiation à la carte on aura 5
animateurs qui seront dans 5 espaces
différents avec avec chacun une offre
qui leur
ressemble pour les familles on a un
animateur qui vous proposera de créer
votre propre théâtre d'ombre on a une
autre plasticienne qui a fait énormément
de recherches sur les artistes femmes
méconnus de notre musée et le présentera
le fruit de ses recherches on pourra
également faire du des du des dessins
autour des statuts extérieurs
qui ont fait
l'objet d'un très important travail de
mise en lumière voilà et c'est des
statuts de Bourdelle qui est un artiste
vraiment immense de cette transition
entre le 19e et le 20/20e siècle
l'histoire du bâtiment les jardins aussi
du musée Maurice
ce monde donc voilà toute cette partie
qui est autour du statuelle R2 à Bourdel
ça vous donne envie de tester le
programme le Jedi l'âme du Jedi pour
vous peut-être Régine c'est ce qui
m'intéresse le plus pour vous Catherine
Noël sur scène on peut aller aussi dans
d'autres endroits des Yvelines le
programme est alléchant on peut tout à
fait je vois qu'il y a beaucoup de
choses en effet à l'échange dans le coin
en tout cas merci à vous deux de d'en
avoir parlé et tous les renseignements à
retrouver bien sûr sur vos différents
sites internet on peut peut-être les
rappeler pour le musée de la ville de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines on trouve les
informations sur skype.fr directement
est-ce que y.fr pour le musée Maurice
Denis sur le musée
c'est un rendez-vous qui se tient dans
le cadre d'un mois une commune on va
écouter tout de suite une présentation
assez bref avec Jodi le jeune médiatrice
culturel de la ville au micro de Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude il y a vraiment un
ordre chronologique on commence donc
autant des Gaulois on a des panneaux
explicatifs il y a des tableaux aussi
avec des cartes
on retrouve des photos on retrouve le
Tarare qui appartenu à la maison des
Coville après la haut du coup au premier
étage on va avoir toute l'histoire
autour des quartiers donc la maquette
notamment du futur quartier de la remise
et on a aussi la reconstitution d'un
salon voilà qui appartenu à une famille
vicinoise qui a de la donnée au Musée de
la Ville donc on parle ici Frédéric
debug une exposition hors les murs qui
se déroule dans le cadre d'un mois une
commune un projet porté par le musée de
la ville déjà quel est le but de cette
exposition si on parle de l'exposition à
Voisins alors c'est tout simplement une
exposition qui permet de retracer
l'histoire de voisins et de représentait
les
le patrimoine du moins les principaux
éléments du patrimoine et qui s'inscrit
effectivement dans un petit dispositif
qu'on a intitulé un moyen de communes et
qui consiste à tour de rôle à valoriser
le patrimoine architectural urbain
artistique et historique d'une commune
de l'agglomération sur l'espace d'un
mois ou presque donc l'idée c'est de
mettre en lumière petit à petit les
douze communes de l'agglomération pas
forcément si exactement c'est ça et à
chaque commune sont dispositif ce qu'on
fait un voisin sera pas forcément la
même chose qu'on a fait par exemple
précédemment à Villepreux ou à Maurepas
ici on a voulu traiter et c'est ce sont
à chaque fois des des programmations qui
sont menées en partenariat étroit avec
avec les communes et ici notre souhait
commun était de présenter l'histoire de
façon un peu générale comme la personne
vient de le rappeler de de l'Antiquité à
nos jours cette histoire un peu générale
de Voisins-le-Bretonneux une histoire
mais aussi des histoires bien sûr de
voisins Bretonneux vous l'avez dit
Villepreux Maurepas
Voisins-le-Bretonneux quels sont les
prochaines étapes quelle est la
prochaine étape
voilà des projets avec différentes
villes notamment la verrière qui se
profile pour 2024 merci beaucoup
Frédéric Debu je rappelle conservatoire
du musée de la ville de
saint-quentin-en-y merci également à
Pierre Marie Vautier d'avoir parlé
également de la Nuit des Musées chargés
du développement touristique et de la
politique des publics on va parler d'une
exposition avec l'invité qui est avec
nous depuis le début de cette émission
c'est Catherine Noël vous dire aussi
Frédéric debuch je sais que vous êtes
pressé si vous voulez partir libre à
vous je vous demanderai juste de passer
sur la droite du plateau pour éviter de
passer devant l'axe caméra alors avec
vous Catherine Noël on va parler dans
cette partie culture et également de ces
animaux de compagnie préféré des
Français des chiens et des chats une
exposition leur est consacré à
Croissy-sur-Seine jusqu'en juillet 16
juillet c'est ça pour la date vous êtes
je le rappelle adjointe au maire en
charge de la culture pour la commune de
Croissy-sur-Seine mais pourquoi
justement accueillir une exposition
dédiée à nos animaux de compagnie et
bien pour la raison suivante en fait on
croit tout on connaît très bien les
chiens et les chats et c'est pas vrai on
se fait beaucoup d'idées là-dessus donc
on a vraiment travaillé en partenariat
donc avec la Cité des sciences et de la
Villette et de la culture pardon et qui
a surtout
travaillé avec des étologues sur cette
cette exposition et donc il y a des tas
de jeux interactifs auxquels on doit
répondre et pour l'avoir fait moi-même
je peux vous dire qu'on n'est pas
toujours dans la réalité on apprend
plein de choses en fait il y a trois
univers dans cette dans cette exposition
il y a une partie qui est dans leur tête
une partie qui est dans leur peau et une
partie qui est dans la dans leur dans la
société l'intégration des animaux dans
la société et oui on se rend compte que
on apprend plein de choses Frédéric
pierre Mario les connaissez bien les
chiens et les chats où il y a peut-être
c'est vrai des petits stéréotypes qu'on
peut avoir on n'est pas forcément en
faisant pas forcément les connaître
est-ce que aussi il y a une démarche
pour Croatie sur scène de dire nous on
est une ville peut-être ami des animaux
en proposant ce type d'exposition ou pas
du tout sûrement une ville ami des
animaux comme toutes les villes on a
j'imagine beaucoup de chiens et chats on
est surtout une ville amie des enfants
oui et puis quand vous faites une
exposition comme ça vous attirez les
enfants les parents et les
grands-parents mais les enfants sont
ravis de venir dans ce genre
d'exposition donc oui on est surtout une
ville qui attire les enfants on a
énormément d'enfants à 6 heures scène et
vous l'avez dit exposition donc créé par
la Cité des Sciences et de l'Industrie
qui existent depuis 2015 elle a
d'ailleurs été aussi conçu avec d'autres
associations à 30 millions d'amis
notamment exactement et nous on
travaille aussi avec une autre
association donc on va en profiter on va
travailler avec une association qui
s'appelle WAF et qui fait de la
médiation tant dans des maisons de
retraite que dans des prisons et donc
c'est très important aussi de de pouvoir
découvrir l'animal pour l'apaisement et
puis donc la médiation c'est quelque
chose de très important de
sensibilisation de découverte autour de
ces animaux de compagnie vous en avez
parlé dans ces trois thèmes s'articule
autour de trois thèmes dans leur peau
dans leur tête dans nos sociétés oui
également exactement dans notre société
c'est surtout pour pour voir comment il
s'intègre aussi dans nos sociétés vous
savez on est les premiers à Croatie à
dire que les gens quelquefois qui ont
des animaux voilà première puisque j'en
ai on n'est pas toujours très propre et
on n'a pas donc c'est aussi une façon de
montrer aux gens qu'un animal il peut
très bien s'intégrer dans une ville à
partir du moment où chacun fait un
effort et ça c'est très important que
chacun fasse un effort là-dessus je
crois qu'il y a aussi une expérience
immersive on peut se mettre un petit peu
dans la tête de nos amis à quatre pattes
il y a une expérience immersive et puis
on travaille aussi avec
le on a des expositions aussi avec
microfolies donc chez nous donc on fait
des tas de choses plus on a la Clé Verte
qui est en fait
un site où on fait découvrir la nature
les animaux qui sont pas forcément des
chiens et des chats qui sont les
insectes etc donc tout ça on met en
combinaison de façon à faire quelque
chose d'assez fourni quoi vous avez pu
tester l'expérience immersive et alors
vous avez trouvé ça comment très bien
sauf que je vais pas forcément non plus
répondu comme il faut à toutes les
questions et oui c'est très intéressant
c'est vraiment franchement à chaque fois
que j'y vais et je discute avec des
parents qui sortent avec leurs enfants
ils sont ravis quoi ils ont appris des
choses insolites
on a beaucoup d'écoles qui viennent on a
beaucoup de centres de loisirs aussi qui
viennent donc oui non c'est à la fois
très pédagogique et à la fois très
ludique je crois qu'on peut aussi
envoyer une photo de son chien et son
chat pour qu'elle soit affichée dans
l'exposition alors c'est ça exactement
en fait les croisillons ont vraiment
participé à cette exposition puisque on
a je sais pas on doit avoir à peu près
300 photos qui ont été envoyées par les
croisillons de leur animal et donc on a
tout un couloir avec plein de photos
évidemment des photos assez rigolotes de
de des chiens et chats et les gens sont
très contents parce que quand ils
viennent en fait ils voient leur animal
voilà dans le château chamaurier donc
c'est c'est assez sympathique et on peut
toujours envoyer sa photo il y a le mec
qui s'affiche
on peut toujours envoyer sa photo voilà
et on le fait avec plaisir un dernier
mot vous l'avez dit le public c'est
familial on peut venir en famille pour
pour cette exposition il faut venir en
famille c'est très sympa au contraire
d'abord je pense que les enfants ne
viennent pas tout seul parce qu'ils ont
aussi besoin d'explication en fait il y
a quand même pas mal de panneaux mais on
a aussi une médiatrice culturelle qui
fait des visites et qui donne un vrai
sens à l'exposition vous avez un animal
de compagnie
allez-y Catherine justement pour revenir
sur ce que vous disiez tout à l'heure
quelle est la chose la plus surprenante
que vous ayez appris
lors de cette exposition
probablement la hauteur des sauts des
différents chiens ou chats et
franchement il y a une espèce d'arche où
on doit sauter pour voir en équivalent
si on y arriverait si on arrive si on y
arrive et je peux vous dire qu'on y
arrive pas et puis des trois choses
est-ce que le chien voit les couleurs
est-ce que le chat voit les couleurs
est-ce que il a une notion de grandeur
voilà donc des tas de choses qu'on a oui
qu'on apprend au fur et à mesure
exactement et pourtant j'ai moi-même un
chien et bon c'est des choses que
j'imaginais pas mais oui c'est assez
drôle en fait merci à Catherine Noël
d'avoir été avec nous je rappelle mes
adjointe en charge de la culture pour la
ville de Croissy-sur-Seine et si vous
êtes intéressé allez-y le mot de la fin
parce que ça s'arrête jamais chez nous
et on rentre dans les vous parliez du
sport tout à l'heure on rentre dans la
coupe du monde de rugby évidemment et
donc notre prochaine exposition
s'institule corps et sport ça va être
une énorme exposition aussi toujours en
partenariat avec la Cité des Sciences et
de l'Industrie toujours à chaleur et ça
va être quelque chose de très très beau
très très chouette cette exposition dont
on parlait sur sur les animaux elle se
tient jusqu'au 16 juillet
voilà et je vous engage à y aller
le
slogan et est tout trouvé merci beaucoup
on va parler à présent de musique dans
le 7 8 avec un événement solidaire on a
commencé à le présenter en début
d'édition ça se passe samedi au prisme
d'Élancourt le Lion's Club d'Élancourt
aqualina organise un concert de jazz au
profit des enfants en situation de
handicap on va recevoir justement des
musiciens qui sont sur scène mais je
vous propose tout de suite d'écouter un
petit extrait
[Musique]
donc les invités qui s'installent en
plus précisément quand le jazz rencontre
la musique classique French master
d'Antoine de San à la voix Clément
Griffo au piano qui seront encore tête
ils m'ont rejoint d'ailleurs en plateau
Antoine qui est à ma gauche et Clément
qui est à ma droite bonsoir à vous
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous et vous
êtes donc revenus accompagner de Thierry
Barba gelata qui est donc le président
du Lion's Club d'Élancourt aqualina qui
organise cette soirée jazz on va parler
justement de ce projet que vous portez
juste déjà une petite question à tous
les deux pourquoi vous vous êtes joint à
cet événement solidaire qu'est-ce qui
vous a poussé à accepter l'invitation du
Lion's Club d'Élancourt aqualina Antoine
moi déjà c'est une belle opportunité de
jouer dans un lieu super et aussi de
jouer pour une
occasion qui compte pour nous voilà que
ce soit un événement humanitaire c'est
on sait que ça comptait pour nous et par
rapport à notre musique aussi clé c'est
la même chose pour vous qu'est-ce qui
vous attiré et c'est par connaissance
aussi par Antoine et c'est des
rencontres comme toujours qui font qu'on
a eu cette belle invitation voilà on le
disait avec un angle solidaire d'aider
les enfants situations de handicap on va
parler justement du projet thérapeutique
qui donc vous allez aider au financement
grâce à cette soirée justement de
proposer ce type de soirée de mêlée
finalement le côté solidaire aux côtés
festif ça c'est très important pour le
Lion's club qui a un côté festif aussi
sur sur la soirée oui il y a le côté
festif il y a aussi le côté l'aspect
culturel là aussi on apporte d'ailleurs
on apporte aussi on donne la possibilité
à cette à ce projet de s'exprimer sur
une scène et puis de faire connaître un
public
particulièrement par exemple on a invité
les
élèves d'écoles de musique venir
assister au concert parce que
effectivement la démarche peut fortement
intéresser notamment les sections jazz
n'est pas que voilà événement solidaire
culturel festifs
on l'a bien compris alors la promesse je
le disais c'est un voyage musical ou
Ravel et Debussy viennent à la rencontre
de kershwin colporteur la musique
classique française va briller au
travers du prisme du jazz et des
musiques actuelles justement parlez-nous
de ce projet frenchmaster je sais pas
qui veut commencer entre Antoine et
Clément mais quels sont les objectifs on
va commencer avec Antoine quels sont les
objectifs les objectifs c'est de faire
connaître au grand public aux jeunes le
patrimoine français de la musique
classique qu'on a de trésors qu'on a qui
sont souvent méconnus et l'idée m'est
venue pendant mes études de jazz ou ce
il arrivait que on écrive la parole sur
des thèmes instrumentaux qui ne sont pas
des thèmes issus de communie musicale
comme beaucoup de standards et je
m'étais dit tiens ce serait super ayant
une étudié la musique classique de faire
la même chose
d'écrire des paroles de trouver des
histoires sur des des morceaux qui
étaient instrumentaux à la base voilà
pour en fait le faire connaître au grand
public et c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai écrit des textes en anglais
principalement pour vraiment que ça que
ces œuvres de musique classique puissent
rentrer dans ce dans ce standard entre
guillemets des chansons de Broadway
faire les des passerelles entre le jazz
et la musique classique française et
c'est possible c'est absolument possible
et justement c'est un projet qui nous
est venu assez naturellement parce que
moi par exemple j'ai fait toutes mes
études en classique mais j'ai toujours
fait de l'improvisation à côté et du
jazz et avec Antoine on a un parcours
qui est assez similaire et parallèle et
on a toujours adoré ces deux musiques là
et donc assez naturellement quand on a
commencé à jouer ensemble il y a
quelques années on a fait des des
parallèles comme ça on s'est dit mais ce
serait super de jouer ça jazz reprendre
ce morceau là le rendre un peu plus pop
et tout parce que là on a vraiment aussi
cette envie comme disait Antoine de
partager la musique au plus grand nombre
et de rendre toutes ces œuvres
magnifiques parfois un peu inconnues
parce que classé cataloguer classique
qui est une musique un petit peu voilà
qui est pas toujours accessible à tout
le monde et on a eu envie de rendre ça
populaire et voilà et mélanger tout ça
et justement ces compositeurs là ils
étaient proches du jazz aussi que ce
soit Ravel Debussy et Forêts ils ont des
harmonies des choses comme ça qui qui
sont proches qui sont très proches de la
musique de jazz ils se sont beaucoup
influencés par par ces musiques là donc
voilà c'est on a entendu ce que donnait
le résultat avec un extrait il faut bien
sûr venir samedi pour voir la suite
justement qu'est-ce qui sera proposé
samedi aux personnes qui viendront voir
cette soirée jazz alors on aura des
certaines offres de classiques donc ça
s'appelle French master en hommage au
mètre français Gravel Debussy 500 et
aussi les ponts qui a pu avoir aussi
avec la musical donc on trouvera des
oeuvres de Gershwin que le porteur on
aura vraiment un côté plus introspectif
comme ce que la musique classique peut
proposer bien souvent et un côté plus
dansant avec les chansons de Broadway
colporteur on a aussi Charlie Chaplin
avec smile voilà
musical au programme on le disait avec
un nombre solidaire Thierry barbagellata
puisque ce sera au profit des enfants
situation de handicap alors plus
précisément ça va servir à financer un
projet thérapeutique de quoi s'agit-il
très précisé d'abord il y a plusieurs
projets qui concernent des structures
qui sont sur le territoire notamment à
proximité à Élancourt Maurepas et la
verrière en gros pour l'essentiel ça va
aider à financer dans un cas un jardin
thérapeutique dans un établissement
qui accueille des jeunes et des enfants
à partir de 12 ans
dans les services de santé mentale
ce type de handicap et puis dans un
autre établissement qui est sûrement pas
pour voilà qui actuellement sur un
projet de salle
multisensorielles qui est un outil qui
permet d'améliorer les conditions de
traitement enfin de
thérapies on imagine des thérapies des
équipements qui sont coûteux et qui
demandent de la solidarité pas forcément
très coûteux mais en tous les cas qui ne
rentrent pas dans les dans les standards
de financement j'avais dit habituel et
pour lequel il faut trouver
effectivement enfin ces organismes là
qui sont plus des organismes à but privé
mais habite non lucratif ou public en
lucratif
donc voilà donc on intervient pour aider
à compléter les financements ou même
à des mettre le premier financement qui
permet de déclencher ensuite d'autres
quelques infos pratiques pour samedi
quel est le prix du billet alors le prix
du biais c'est 15 euros on peut réserver
à l'avance on peut réserver à l'avance
sur le site alors directement alors pour
ceux qui ont accès
à la au visuel avec le
QR code sinon sur le site du lion par le
hello asso aussi enfin c'est super
d'Élancourt aqualina et on retombe
facilement sur
pour ceux qui n'ont pas la possibilité
d'utiliser le
QR code c'est la solution on le rappelle
au programme donc samedi 20h30 pour le
début et c'est au prisme d'Élancourt au
profit des enfants en situation de
handicap et il y aura sur scène on le
disait à ce projet French master avec
Antoine de San et Clément Griffo qui
était avec mon plateau juste pour
préciser qu'il y aura un album qui va
sortir cette année aussi et en plus qui
est exceptionnel samedi c'est qu'on a la
chance d'inviter deux musiciens de
vraiment de haute volée de jazzman Elie
Martin Charrière à la batterie et Kim
bayonneco à la contrebasse et donc ça va
être ça va prendre une belle ampleur
avec ces deux génies du jazz donc voilà
un album absolument préparation aussi
pour 2020 qui va arriver à la fin de
l'année on est en train de préparer tout
ça donc rendez-vous samedi merci à vous
deux merci également à Thierry barbares
président du Lion's Club d'Élancourt
aqualina on ouvre tout de suite une page
sport dans le 7 8
[Musique]
et on débute avec la défaite de plaisir
en 16ème de finale de Fédérale 2 de
rugby les Yvelinois se sont inclinés
dimanche à domicile contre Saint-Priest
sur le score de 1810 il joueront donc la
suite de leur aventure est en tronc
d'accéder en fédéral 1 lors du match
retour qui est prévu dimanche 14 mai
dans la banlieue lyonnaise le résumé du
match avec Nicolas dandry et Patrick
Jacques de dixman
une entame de seconde période
déterminante dans ce 16e de finale de
fédéral 2 très serré entre les deux
équipes disparu à la mi-temps plaisir
est en position favorable pour marquer
un essai
mais les lieux de Saint-Priest
intercepte et mène ce contraste à ça
difficile à digérer pour les plaisirsois
l'interception a nous fait mal nous fait
mal parce que en fait c'est sur ces
coups là c'est soit nous on marque soit
c'est eux voilà c'est un coup du sort
donc ça fait un peu mal à la tête
surtout à la reprise comme ça mais bon
il y avait encore 38 minutes derrière
donc voilà c'est vrai qu'on a pas su on
n'a pas su rebondir et pourtant plaisir
à dominer cette partie contre les
joueurs du Rhône mais comme le dit le
coach Sébastien rocali n'est pas gagné
encore une fois l'adage
c'est valorisé aujourd'hui pour nous
malheureusement au niveau de
l'implication des gars il y a
strictement rien à dire par contre en
termes de maîtrise effectivement on a on
n'a pas su conclure dans les zones de
marque et on savait très bien que
notamment phase finale ça fait la
différence donc ça c'est vraiment
dommage maintenant maintenant il y a
quand même de très bonnes choses à
retenir donc voilà on sait que on sait
que c'est pas fini
on a vu ce qu'on était capable de faire
face à cette équipe donc bon bah c'est
tout donner sur le retour rien n'est
perdu pour les plaisirs ouais ils se
sont inclinés 10 à 18 sur ce match aller
et sont prêts à tout donner lors du
match retour à l'état d'esprit de
conquérant il va falloir aller là en
plus on a du retard on part avec -8 - 8
points donc voilà esprit de conquête et
puis de surtout se faire plaisir parce
que là aujourd'hui on s'est pas fait
plaisir du tout
plaisir sera en mission ce dimanche 14
mai du côté de Saint-Priest dans la
région lyonnaise
et en parlant de rugby l'Union Rugby
Club 78 propose samedi prochain un grand
une grande journée dédiée au rugby
féminin s'est en partenariat avec le
Comité Départemental de la Ligue
Île-de-France de rugby ça se passe
samedi prochain au stade André Boniface
Élancourt 11 équipes franciliennes des
catégories des moins de 15 ans et des
moins de 12 ans s'affront toute la
journée sur du jeu à 7 ou 10 joueuses
une bonne occasion de découvrir le rugby
féminin le football est là 27e journée
du championnat de National de Poissy
c'est largement imposé à domicile face à
Évreux sur le score de 5 buts à deux à
la rencontre était samedi dernier une
rencontre sur courant alternatif pour
les pitiaquer retour sur ce match avec
Nicolas dandry et Michael
en faveur de Poissy après une première
mi-temps compliquée l'épicéa qui ont
remporté cette rencontre 5 buts à deux
face à Évreux pourtant tout avait bien
commencé pour les Normands d'abord sur
penalty
puis sur une action collective conclue
par un centre repris face au but
jouant en réaction par rapport à leurs
adversaires
à chaque fois on répondait quand même
marqué parce qu'on a pris des buts aussi
sur des erreurs individuelles donc le
fait que nous on arrive à marquer
derrière ça rebooster l'équipe à chaque
fois il manquait juste à monter en
intensité à plus d'applications plus de
course et plus de concentration juste un
petit peu plus dans chaque domaine et je
pense que on a mis ça en application ça
a été nettement meilleur au retour des
vestiaires le score de 2 évolue très
rapidement voici accélère après un
premier but en première mi-temps Amadou
Konaté inscrit un doublé
l'attaquant est aussi passeur décisif
l'épicciacée retrouve le goût de la
victoire une saveur qu'il n'avait plus
connu depuis le 4 mars et un succès à
l'extérieur contre Guingamp 2 ils
occupent aujourd'hui la sixième place au
classement à la trêve on est premier et
là on était toujours pas maintenu donc
voilà c'est mes l'essentiel c'est ça
c'est que on a fait là on a aujourd'hui
on a réussi à prendre les points ça
faisait longtemps ça nous fait du bien
et il reste trois matchs il faudra bien
les négocier déjà il nous manque 7
points en classement par cette perte
bête donc voilà c'est déjà des gens
doivent finir plus haut déjà
comptablement et on a un peu lâché au
moins que au moment qu'on jouait plus
rien pour rappel en septembre dernier
l'as Poissy avait perdu 7 points au
classement une sanction suite à une
erreur administrative par rapport à des
licences de joueurs
ambiance survoltante au Palais des
Sports d'Élancourt l'Arena élancourtoise
a accueilli samedi et dimanche dernier
les phases finales du championnat de
France de badminton les quatre meilleurs
clubs de France se sont affrontés durant
le week-end un événement accueilli et
co-ganisé par le Club des volants
d'Élancourt une première pour
l'association sportive on écoute à ce
propos le président Nicolas montpelot et
quelques joueurs finalistes au micro de
Michael el Mirro en terme de spectateur
nous sommes au-dessus des attentes on a
vendu plus de 600 places aujourd'hui je
pense c'est vraiment un record on a
réussi à remplir plus de la moitié du
Palais des Sports rien qu'en spectateur
ensuite on a toutes les équipes qui sont
présentes plus une cinquantaine de
joueurs une centaine de bénévoles de
présents aussi ça représente beaucoup de
monde sur le Palais des Sports
d'Élancourt donc sont des joueurs qui
sont quasiment tous internationaux on a
le numéro 1 français numéro 2 français
également simple le numéro 5 mondial en
double mixte ainsi que sa partenaire qui
joue pour une autre équipe donc vraiment
des joueurs de haut niveau sur sur ces
deux jours je m'attendais pas à voir
autant de monde donc ça c'est top j'aime
bien quand il y a de l'ambiance donc là
c'est cool en plus c'est une salle qui
s'apprête bien au badminton ou ça
résonne bien donc
c'était vraiment un bon moment pour nous
Chambly ça nous permet de montrer notre
statut et de comment dire de leader etc
donc c'est vrai que c'est un événement
particulier pour nous pas s'y permet de
comment dire de rassembler toute notre
équipe et d'être présent à un moment T
la Coupe de France de BMX de VTT SKF
trial non pas BMX mais VTT
vendredi et dimanche les 150 meilleurs
riders français et étrangers du moment
vont se retrouver au Stadium Julien
Absalon l'événement sera lancé
officiellement vendredi à partir de
17h15 et va donc se poursuivre tout le
weekend des animations sont également au
menu du rendez-vous qui est ouvert à
tous l'entrée libre toutes les
informations sur le site Internet et de
la ville des pônes ça se passe également
ce week-end et plus précisément du côté
du stade Bernard Giroud à plaisir le
Gally Athletic Club organise la
troisième édition de son meeting
d'athlétisme avec la section locale du
plaisir Athletic Club et la municipalité
on en parle avec deux invités retour
déjà de Romain vanderwigerts rebonsoir
qui est avec nous je le précise
président du Gali atlétic club et vous
êtes accompagné de Fabien orest bonsoir
vous êtes vous le vice-président de la
section locale du plaisir Athletic Club
on disait tout à l'heure romain un
événement qui
[Musique]
200 mètres 1500 mètres et 400 mètres et
puis tout ça ça commence à 14h et puis
et puis après ça va se dire ça va se
dire ça va se dérouler au fur et à
mesure au fur et à mesure du nombre
d'athlètes qui sera présent sur place
donc une jauge qui peut monter à 150
est-ce que le niveau est bon qui qui
sont-ils c'est ses athlètes
on va avoir au club
Lina desmed qui était la numéro 1
française sur 400 mètres il y a
catégorie junior cet hiver après
d'autres athlètes s'inscrivent au fur et
à mesure de au fur et à mesure des de la
semaine là donc on attend de voir et
pour vraiment fixer un petit peu un
petit peu tout ça avec des athlètes
venus de toute l'Île-de-France même de
la France je crois qu'il y avait des
Normands qui étaient venus sur la
première édition notamment ouais on
avait eu quelques Normands alors
principalement c'est vrai que on va
toucher par exemple le 93 1178 92 91 on
touche vraiment tous les tous les
départements et Vinois et aussi
l'Île-de-France après principalement
c'est aussi comment dire
avoir le avoir les clubs qui sont
proches de plaisir et aussi attirer
après par la suite tout le reste qui va
avec quoi vous êtes que dans
l'organisation vous serez vous en
compétition je serais aussi athlète avec
Romain aussi
mètres ce sera dommage de pas participer
à notre propre
et au niveau du calendrier on est plutôt
sur un début de saison en extérieur
comment ça se passe on est sur un début
de saison on vient de faire le premier
tour des Interclubs donc l'événement de
l'athlétisme français là le deuxième
tour arrive dans dans deux semaines donc
on est en plein début de la saison
estivale donc c'est pour ça on a mis à
meeting en fait entre les deux tours
interclub pour pour conduire pour tout
le monde puisse avoir un début de saison
bien rempli quoi quels sont les
ingrédients de la réussite dernière
question on va peut-être poser la
question à vous deux et commencer par
Fabien pour que ce troisième meeting
soit une réussite faudrait déjà du
soleil ce serait déjà la météo des
dernières heures n'est pas très bonne
donc ce serait ce serait déjà un bon
point de départ après si on pouvait
vraiment avoir des athlètes de tous
niveaux et surtout de niveau équivalent
pour que une personne se conjugue pas
toute seule elle est quelqu'un avec qui
se battre puisque mine de rien si on
court après un chrono s'il peut y avoir
un petit peu un petit duel durant la
course c'est toujours quelque chose de
sympa romain le mot de la fin avez-vous
le mot de la fin est-ce que vous
souhaitez bonne humeur de beaux
résultats et une quatrième édition pour
l'année prochaine et donc troisième
édition je le rappelle au programme ce
samedi du côté du stade Bernard Giroud à
plaisir et donc début des compétitions
14 heures sur donc ce complexe du stade
Bernard Giroud a plaisir on termine ses
actualités sportives avec une annulation
annulation du 77e 77e Paris
Mantes-la-Jolie cycliste ce dimanche 14
mai on parle d'une compétition de
cyclisme féminin ça devait être la
première édition de cette compétition
féminine organisatrice de l'événement
laisse mentais cyclisme explique qu'une
manche de Coupe de France se tient à la
même date il était donc impossible de
maintenir ce Paris Mantes face à cette
compétition essentielle pour plusieurs
équipes une date de report de votre tête
devrait être fixé en collaboration avec
la Fédération Française de Cyclisme il y
a en face de vous Véronique Ithurbide
qui nous a rejoint au cours de cette
interview on sort Véronique pour parler
de vos insolites c'est tout de suite
dans le 7 8
des informations qui ont peut-être
échappé à l'attention de nos
téléspectateurs heureusement vous êtes
là Véronique pour nous les relais on va
débuter par un menu qui a retenu votre
attention et qui sera suivi et qui sera
servi même au restaurant Les 4 Saisons à
Versailles oui alors c'est un chef qu'on
connaît mauditako qui donc de saison qui
fait ses clashs
du roi qui depuis 7 ans et donc au cas
de saison il est d'origine malienne et
il a eu envie de nous faire découvrir sa
cuisine natale la cuisine de sa mère
tout simplement donc le jeudi midi et le
soir à emporter vous aurez des menus
maliens typiquement maliens alors je
vais pas vous savez ça peut être du mafé
du tiep du poulet yassa du tia cri vous
connaissez c'est pas où vous voulez que
je vous en dise un petit peu plus alors
moi je connais le mafé mais pour le coup
les autres places on peut peut-être
détailler un plat allez
poivron et céleri marinées et puis en
dessert vous avez du tiaré ou du rond et
le 11d ça me tente bien c'est billes de
semoule de blé lait de coco crème
fraîche citronnée voilà ça va nous
réchauffer
glacial ce sera pas trop et on va
poursuivre ces informations insolites
alors avec une performance dans le vide
ça va se passer samedi à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux il sera question
de Highline de slackline je compte sur
vous pour détailler
vous évoluez sur une sangle qui fait 2,5
cm en général c'est sur une longueur de
de 4 mètres et quelques et la secte
c'est au sol enfin c'est pas tout à fait
au sol mais c'est pas d'accord et après
il y a des des
viandes c'est pas des des viandes des
variantes merci
des variantes à la slackline notamment
la highline et là Highline en fait c'est
la même chose mais très très haut je
crois
notamment dans un paysage de montagne
par exemple voilà sur un glacier alors
là c'est tellement haut qu'il faut une
sécurité donc un baudrier en général
permet de si on tombe de passer écraser
au sol et donc il va y avoir un
événement à Voisins-le-Bretonneux c'est
samedi après-midi de 14 à 18h une
initiation donc pour démarrer la
slackline et aussi une des grosses
rations qui sera faite par un champion
qui s'appelle Lucas Giovanni Moreira qui
est le recordman mondial de la plus
longue traversée en 2021 donc là pour
l'occasion il va
surplomber survoler enfin bref traverser
l'écoquartiers sur une Highline de 110
mètres tendue entre deux grues à 40
mètres de haut
quartier qui est en train de voir le
jour petit à petit à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux à proximité décidé
de cette nouvelle guerre de la ligne 18
donc si on lève les yeux au ciel on aura
cette personne grue vous verrez Lucas
Giovanni Moreira en train d'évoluer et
sinon c'est ouvert à tous pour
l'initiation à la slackline un petit peu
plus basse donc voilà samedi et on va
terminer avec un défilé mode un peu
spécial qui va se dérouler à Versailles
j'ai l'impression que c'est d'occuper
votre weekend Grégory donc samedi c'est
fait voilà et dimanche alors je vous
encourage à vous rendre à la mairie de
Versailles parce que c'est un événement
partenariat avec la mairie de Versailles
c'est Alison Laurent qui est une
styliste qui est spécialisée dans
l'obside clean l'obsideling c'est en
fait
prendre des des objets et les
revaloriser les transformer mais en
mieux toujours en mieux évidemment une
veste pourrie aux manches mettons troué
vous enlevez les manches vous en faites
un gilet enfin voilà c'est c'est un peu
ça le principe alors elle a décidé elle
a une boutique depuis une boutique
atelier depuis 16 ans Versailles et elle
a décidé Alison Laurent sa boutique
c'est quand tu Guérin elle a décidé de
d'organiser des défilés donc là c'est un
défilé collectif de mode éco-responsable
et vous me dites d'accord parce que ça
suffit
alors vous aurez collectif donc ça veut
dire plusieurs ça veut dire des
créateurs de d'accessoires de bijoux et
de vêtements c'est dimanche 14 mai 15h15
et quoi d'autre et bien c'est un peu une
alternative à la fast fashion voilà
la consommation de vêtements à outrance
neuf bien sûr est-ce que dit Alison
c'est qu'il n'y a pas de de bonnes
créations attendez parce que je fais la
maligne je cherche mes phrases et je
vais faire
la meilleure création est celle qui ne
nécessite pas de matière neuve voilà on
fait une belle phrase pour terminer
cette petite chronique donc voilà on a
une idée pour aller manger l'idée pour
sortir samedi et une autre idée pour
sortir dimanche est-ce qu'il y a une
idée qui a retenu votre attention manger
manger
on avait déjà vu ça à 50 ans en Yvelines
juste à côté de l'immeuble de TV 70
justement on avait relié effectivement
la line entre l'immeuble de TV 78 et
celui de la Bibliothèque Universitaire
de l'UVSQ donc voilà ça c'est à voir
samedi et du côté de
Voisins-le-Bretonneux merci beaucoup à
Véronique on se revoit mardi prochain
mais avec plaisir
à la présentation aussi de l'émission
veigrist sur TV 78 vous voulez dire un
mot très rapide allez 30 secondes 30
secondes aujourd'hui pardon il y aura un
VIP justement avec Alison Laurent pour
parler de de l'obsèques Ling et de la
mode éco-responsable voilà
78 merci beaucoup juste avant de vous
laisser on va jeter un dernier coup
d'oeil aux prévisions météo de demain
et donc peu ou pas d'amélioration en vue
pour les conditions météo de la journée
de demain de la pluie annoncée dans la
matinée yvelinoise le ciel sera
légèrement plus clair vers
Mantes-la-Jolie Houdan et Rambouillet il
fera en moyenne entre 11 et 12 degrés
l'après-midi le ciel sera orageux dans
le secteur de Rambouillet Houdan côté
température compter 15 degrés dans la
partie Nord et Centre du département 14
degrés et dans le sud des Yvelines voilà
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 merci de nous
avoir suivi c'est pour moi l'occasion de
souhaiter la bienvenue au petit Thomas
et de féliciter par la même occasion les
parents nouvelle édition demain du 7 8
même heure vous retrouverez la
présentation Mathilde Franco belle
soirée sur TV 78
[Musique]